thank you for joining us armenia's prime
minister says 49 of his soldiers have
been killed in fighting with azerbaijan
the fighting began along the border
early on tuesday armenia says the azeri
army began shelling military positions
around three cities but azerbaijan says
it was responding to a buildup of
armenian landmines and weapons
leaders are working to stabilize the
situation and their reports of a shaky
ceasefire let's speak to fareed shafiev
who's the chairman of the center of
analysis of international relations and
a former azeri ambassador he joins us
from baku thank you very much for being
with us
we have right now each side accusing the
other of starting these latest
hostilities what sparked the recent
flare-up in violence as far as
azerbaijan is concerned
well uh as we know all that azerbaijan
suffered from 30 years of armenian
occupation of international recognized
territory
and war in 2020 ended with the
liberation of being
part of azerbaijan's territory now both
countries are working towards the peace
agreement peace treaty and um but it was
quite positive development uh in
brussels on the auspices of the european
union
uh speaking um about the auspices of the
president charlemagne
unfortunately
azerbaijan made proposal
uh to
establish peace based on the mutual
recognitions of territorial integrity of
two countries unfortunately this last
meeting which happened in
end of august didn't go well because the
armenian side again tried to bring to
the table the issue of so-called
nagorno-karabakh basically they're
speaking about independence of
nagorno-karabakh
so we have the
peace proposal peace package which
includes territorial integrity as a core
principle of international law
in the meantime an armenian side trying
to bring back the issue of independence
of nagorno-karabakh and the different
phraseology but what was it what was it
sir that started this latest uh fighting
and and who started it the the armenians
are accusing azerbaijan of of shelling
their military positions around three
cities what happened yeah
yeah you um happened to that from the
territory of armenia where there was
always some shellings and uh some uh
strikes
basically if we look at the history of
the conflict everything happened on the
territory of azerbaijan destruction
military actions
and this time armenia also launched a
series of provocations
but azerbaijan would decide at this time
to respond more decisively
it was large-scale response and i think
from now on armenia won't have a free
exercise you know
just shelling and because of some
security umbrella from the third
countries azerbaijan
was cautious to respond speaking of
third countries there are some in
armenia who say azerbaijan is being
encouraged by russia to provoke armenia
what do you respond to that
well
armenia is russian ally russia has
military base in in
in armenia this is complete nonsense
sorry but everyone knows that
these two countries armenia and russia
are member of the same military unit
military alliance
the specific areas that have been
targeted in the last 24 hours are in the
south of armenia what what is the
significance of these areas to
azerbaijan
there are some military installations
including air defense system s 300 and
some other military installation so we
the owl the minister of defense of
azerbaijani
of azerbaijan acted against those
military targets
russian peacekeepers were deployed as
part of the ceasefire which was broken
by president putin in 2020 to end the
conflict over nagano karba
but they've now been replaced what is um
azerbaijan sense of where the situation
is headed and would azerbaijan like to
see more russian involvement or a third
party perhaps negotiate a ceasefire a
permanent more solid ceasefire between
the two sides
you know we offered armenia to work on
bilateral basis will probably
you know some interlocutors or the
mediators like european union will be
beneficial and will be useful
but again we prefer to resolve our
wishes bilaterally and establish
long-term uh platform for peace which is
peace treaty based on the mutual
recognition of territorial integrity
thank you for talking to us farid
shafiaf chairman of the center for
analysis of international relations in
baku thank you very much for your time